[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone we've made it we made it
it's Monday and we're streaming from the
Xfinity Cena smart home and we're gonna
play some layers of fear too
I've played a little bit of it we're a
little bit past first few chapters we're
embarking on the third chapter yup it's
gonna be scary time you know everyone in
the office had a great time laughing at
me getting jump scared so now it's
y'all's turn we figure why now right
might as well put you back into the
ringer but yeah why don't we jump in
[Music]
like they said x3 that is what we're up
to now it's called bloody roots so
basically if you played layers if you're
one it was like about a struggling
artist like painter and you know all
that jazz so this is kind of following
the same format different storyline with
an actor now so now we're on this boat
and you know a lot of crazy things going
on it's all nonsense and crazy but yeah
so here we are so let's just and you
told me you skip some doors we're gonna
force you to go through all of those
doors I'll get scared with you it's fine
it's sure yeah but fun times here at the
the C net smart home I mean when you
have as many devices as you have
connected in this house it's just it's
it is what it is but it's pretty cool
stuff though like you can't really see
it other than TV right now which is an
LG o LED wallpaper TV it's like super
thin it's like thinner than our phone
yes literally thinner than my phone if
you can see this it's like you know
seems pretty good alright okay alright
so you just got past the last chapter
and who you are so this thing right here
it started with me a few letters in it
and then every chapter I've completed it
kind of fills in a little bit more it's
also eerie right because I'm trying to
spin it fast and it's like slow turn
well because you said you've already
been scared a couple time on some of the
yeah slow-slow like I'll pick something
up like you know off the table and then
like the first one was like a mirror and
I turned it over there was like a scary
face on it like this are you I was like
you know normal piece of paper pick it
up so whatever you know all right so you
have this thing which kind of just shows
you how this feature works and then
later on probably in this chapter a few
other moments I had to use this to
actually go through there and get a door
so the puzzles have been pretty cool so
far what was run oh yeah l/2 so we
figured we just kind of get past some of
the introductory stuff yeah so that's
part of the reason why we're in act 3 so
yeah so yeah and if you guys like what
you see then make sure you head over and
get the game so you can play it from the
fricken there's no other way you act on
instinct you see you react it's so easy
to pull your strings alright alright
yeah that's the trippy thing about this
game to you is like every time you open
a door if you go back through that door
nine times out of ten it's not what you
you're not going back to where you
walked in from hmm so everything is
always changing there's always like
something you know different
every time you go through like the same
areas so it's pretty trippy alright I
just walked outside good to see you
chase saying hey Persia Herrick hello
thanks for stream thank you for tuning
in thanks everyone for tuning in
we appreciate it crime says don't get
you baited I'm pretty sure we're gonna
get you baited oh yeah it's gonna I
won't personally baited but I will I
might scare you live here and probably
kind of freak out here so we'll see look
at all the is that fish yeah yeah
endless supply here you'll never start
all right so yeah just pathname we can
like turn knobs and everything some of
it seems like useless but I feel like at
some point I'm gonna have to you know
mess with this stuff maybe I don't know
we'll see it but Oh again oh did I die
last time Oh run I'll kiss I have to run
okay
that we entered an actual like thing you
see you find out it's so easy to pull
your strings okay so we died just now
yeah I might have died again hmm or
maybe I'm not walking the right way
we'll see ah of course chapter three is
gonna begin like this the other thing
too is okay I'm just like press rewind
and start the stream all over again hi
hi sorry one chapter wash Xfinity Z
that's right uh the other thing too is
like so because you're not doing
something before you go I don't I don't
know outside of like a little bit I do
know about the game okay so there's
always check I'm just trying to go
through a different door your chats got
our back to chat okay so yeah here's
another machine oh maybe that's why do I
have to put this bad boy in there
start it up let's watch a movie they
kind of make you start each chapter was
something similar did it
what's seeped into the earth becomes
fodder a few the dialogue too sometimes
gives you hints on what you're supposed
to do which is become a foundation okay
that could be a hint
[Music]
thinking of what could
[Music]
it's like so eerie okay interesting I'm
getting some vibes here now I'm waiting
again I'm waiting to get a jump scare
and I don't have to like toggle this
audio down you ever know Riley you just
get like oh you could just get our
random like audio cue like yeah you know
audio thank you our majority of the
reason I get really jump scared okay so
you think oh now we're definitely
couldn't go that other way oh also just
so you know I'm that helpful is what
does it say okay triangle scrat so you
hear that whispering I dunno that means
there's something nearby that I can pick
up and look at which is definitely how I
got beat it's probably at this item
right here see I flipped it over like
that and then I got jumps good so but
not everything does that so actually I
think I don't know only one curse you
gotta have the creepy little kids oh my
goodness it's so much TV which is even
more you okay good I think I could we
could try boosting it but it has like a
calibration setting in the settings so I
need to gotta like spin it around but
there you go out oh man and like if you
look around thing so dark feels like I
just follow the light
okay um locked all right
why am I so short why is this so crooked
this is interesting
am i that little kid that was talking so
like it's not really you're an actor so
you see a lot of these little points
that like tell you to go certain places
[Music]
usually everything will be locked if you
can't go in there is really trippy
looking but let's do this okay hearing
some noises more stairs let me just make
sure yeah I like it I like process of
elimination here that need the key to
the kitchen well no oh yeah good chance
for it to real Tech's sitting every new
real a pirate film gotcha once these
notes are like yeah the film's gonna be
great and OH what if you have to
eventually that's different
sometimes things will move around you'll
pick something up and look at it you'll
turn it around they'll be organic really
at all locks we I have a key did I not
pick up that key let's go back well I'm
gonna kill our - now you know what it's
part just low I'll let the rest of chat
make confirm or deny I turned it up a
bit though alright I definitely picked
up the key Oh
we're gonna use it for this door action
oh we cook in faithful servants for
tonight we brew a ghoulish concoction
the world strangest you
yeah little kids Oh
oh boy okay I hear game can hear okay
cuz it game sounds long and go vote I
just boosted it so it should be better
now tell me if it's not climb the steps
or too short what come on can you put
stuff into it
what's this above it yeah some garlic
seasoning well it's actually not letting
me grab on to it so maybe I need a spoon
you got a oh there's two things in that
cabinet you check both right one was a
note and one was oh you just opened it
yes
thought maybe it was like a the lid or
something to help there's some spoons
yeah went from kitchen - what in the
world is this we got color now we've
evolved oh yeah I cook that brain
seasoned by sadness sadness that supreme
seasoning - alright cook some brains oh
yeah they'll never know what kind of
stew we're making like brains oh boy I
might have to run from looting you hear
whispers yeah maybe it needs more what
else the brains is not enough let's see
okay oh man it's dark
oh yeah oh yeah oh do I need to get that
before you kiss it or am I gonna die you
have a prompt tone up by conflict
savaged by gas ago you hungry - close
the door on him um oh wow you're not you
you alright he I guess he doesn't fit
down the door through the door wow I
would have I would a hundred percent
close the door like nope
see you later big ol nope
these days and it comes in here I'll
close it though for real oh he would
have came write anything you want to go
see if he's still there yeah let's play
with fate he's not there there's no way
he still JK he's there he's sleeping
yeah he died of hunger perhaps any more
what's up gate how you doing
subject design oh yeah that's a man
again the rat oh oh my gosh oh you woke
up wait is he gonna kill the rap for me
or do I need that axes I'll kill you do
I need that
come on man do it okay ha large by
knowing Hodgins has lost all its glory
you think that's it okay okay so you got
a heart in like what a lie and a brain
Oh huh Java Leena what up crew what up
[Music]
Oh core today I had a feeling that door
you know it was like the one straight
ahead like no it's never that door it's
never that easy
oh boy why do I do that we didn't need
to wake up the Beast oh man he more than
woke up that's for sure but now we can
run right up in there
you sound like that's a good thing I
know it's like they make you you're only
it looks faint a magical oh now we're
interesting the set follow the screening
the black wanderer alright we got a
sneak peek at the black wander okay here
we go into the vent oh movies almost
over time to go I think we gotta get out
of here lest we get caught it's a rated
R movie where child so what is the story
about so know you're like an actor and
you get this gig to be in this movie and
so you get to this boat which is really
gonna shoot it and then now you're like
on this journey to like you know become
the character and like really like step
outside of your comfort zone and you
know become the world's greatest actor
or whatever but once you get onto the
boat there's like no one there you see
all these notes everywhere that says
you've requested to have this part of
the boat blocked off so at first you're
like oh okay
maybe it's because there's no one around
because we didn't want anybody around
for filming whatever whatever but then
stuff starts feeling really weird we got
got yeah oh you know no no I'm getting
complains about noises up on the balcony
gotcha
gotta be worried about the balcony you
never know if you're leaving you're no
in this death above
so yeah it's pretty cool
gotta jiggle it come on you can do it
there you go
wait you see we went through this before
and now we're back yeah but you got
another key though to the bedroom you
got to go into the darkness
oh that's light yeah this is all light
oh but that will be a thing later on I'm
sure whoever who would have thought the
Beast would like light should be the
opposite the dressers sick ooh
picture well you know I'm always scared
to turn around something because
sometimes you know your character turn
around kind of fast and sometimes it
doesn't sound like is this like a cute
alike wait we came in here well you
definitely got the whispers is there a
note there on that stack of books oh
great
pirate time she's very friendly
sure she is it's probably a ghost it's
always the kitchen a hook
don't forget about the light oh we're in
here now oh man yeah oh I hear something
oh man okay I can't be the only one Chad
I hear stuff man see it's this thing oh
whoa oh oh man I have to zoom in okay I
always hate zooming in on see yeah I get
it
what's in the Maui's I got a oh boy
I'm little oh man
okay so do they want us to put it on
that picture I hear oh the pictures gone
that's great is it yeah it was over here
oh the statue you can inspect later well
they want me to put it there
you were always bad oh yeah a blight
upon this family I give everything I get
in return
gratitude little heart is that too much
I'm like getting ready to grab this
paper off of the statue it goes crazy oh
lucky break and ice up my sleeve that's
all I need
my heart the blinds are basically a
lucky break an ice up my sleeve break an
ace up his sleeve they get angry yeah
yeah we gotta get we gotta give him
something let me take his ace oh he
sounds sad now about it how would you
like this note not having it
yeah you know what maybe maybe the case
is is somewhere in regular world okay
I like the OD on the ground no no again
cuz homeboy was real mad and I don't got
no aces ace up my sleeve so I mean
basically we need to get the card I
would assume right he's looking for a
way to cheat in this game you know right
and I just picked up a necklace which I
also don't see in my inventory oh there
it is okay
[Applause]
hey sup asleep we check the sleeves you
need more than an ace your hand sucks oh
man a sub sleeve okay she's got some
sleeves on oh wait I can get on the bed
come on and get on top of this can't
jump so I didn't go on top of the bed
when I had this yeah yeah so let's try
that
oh I'm sorry I'm standing on your bed
but I needed to find this okay okay I'm
gonna feel I have to find it you have to
take it oh wait okay
don't be forgotten okay so let's take
this Betty leave everything and then
let's go put it on that thing again and
then give him his ace for his
the blackened tragedy
where'd he go , just kidding okay
Razia I got three aces now no you beat
that we are wait
yeah let me show you No
the music doesn't know all right like it
okay you know what I felt like oh ha ha
I know I see myself oh my god it's the
Beast it's pretty sad it falls over
there okay okay okay we have a doorway
the way is open it had to just give me a
little bit to get us there that's right
who figured out the puzzle give her back
up here
we're supposed to be something around
the banister okay Oh another keys go
someone's just leaving all their tears
on this end we gotta go I know we
haven't had too many okay that's got to
be a good thing we're progressing I
believe progress or did I because I did
this last time that I fail and it's
taking me back to the beginning again I
really hope not
about to find out
co-ceo things well yeah what do you
think cuz you got a new key though yeah
as a basement unless you were supposed
to go back the other way which is kind
of weird because that you would think
that you would want you to show this
wiring oh my gosh there's definitely
more noises this is the beef okay so
okay that was there before the basement
actually is so the answer what I dislike
this freezer cute to not be in the light
I know there you go what nope but the
line told us to go there oh boy okay
sure your selfie one-eyed freak Oh spare
I remember opening to where me like
there stairs so is this one what's up I
don't like and the controller is
vibrating I'm like
yeah all right we used to keep we use
the key for sure crowd comes too cruel
we look for a place to hide okay
yes serious I'm gonna need this later I
know it excuse me I'm at the right
height
all right well hopefully it'll let me in
when I need it
oh my god oh my god sir how you doing
today me I'm doing great
Oh God it wasn't even anything scary you
didn't get me game but you got hurt they
thought they could get me but they
couldn't oh you're filling the box I
think you're feeling the box okay fair
enough
oh yeah another one another man okay
same same code 90 90 oh man my guy is
like drunk yeah man he's drunk with fear
okay are you gonna put the head in the
box yes
head number two how many would you like
why are you here you're here for the
psychological scares ya to watch strain
the game tried to jump scare me and
Persia I guess that's all I needed from
that Jonathan how you doing what's a
demand
Clell sapper sapper super super ok no we
need more heads yep we just to was not
enough you know 3 spry the charm I go
down got probably go down that dark
hallway we've just lived down that
diagram to the left though like
literally into the darkness oh you think
that it was a dead end
yeah I just got spooked and I was like
I'm out of here
yeah you in there now yeah got me right
I'm a guy real talk that's how I got me
but she kind of scared me first and then
I saw ok I know it's funny whatever the
hell that thing was they looked cartoon
the Beast I hear it hungry it's fine I
know it was like a little like spice
definitely not that scary it a hundred
percent got me I'm like I can't even
like I wasn't looking at the screen
alright
[Music]
I'm gonna go in there anyway
yeah three heads that are not enough oh
god I'm Chinese
that's just a hide so that's the dock in
bays okay ba this coming quick get in
okay Natalie get in okay
right we're safe gotta be safe oh I
didn't like what I saw there which head
fits yeah it's gonna be locked
okay now you could get me game got her
though open it again could possibly
happen
I see it's only good for one let's see
no this one's looking the other way that
way like he's like oh he's locked a lot
above oh that was that oh okay alright
let's do it again where what room key do
we have now let's see some haunted
children come one just I use my strong
iron did it oh okay hmm
we're gonna be fine you guys are gonna
be a-okay ah all right here we go this
now Oh wonderful that looks like the
monster actually about chases yeah I
didn't like I didn't like what I saw
this well I said I said like before she
even got out of the crate I saw the
heads on that like out of the corner of
my eye I'm like this can't be good this
how could how could seeing four heads be
good at all okay oh man this one too but
like the controllers by rating let me in
okay oh that was my fault
that was me still rotating the joystick
and then I like it fine oh god okay
being that bird got Thanos - oh boy
you're singing okay
oh here we go okay cool shiver me
timbers oh is that the I'm a little kid
okay we didn't die we didn't die go on
oh we got a gun I guess shoot these
ghosts
oh boy time to monster okay it'll be by
your hands by your action oh man oh
you're gonna make me shoot him or I can
shoot one of these guys cuz I hate us
whoa I'm voicing I don't want you Oh
see this price again I'm voicing it's
like they give you something give it
which one is it I know I think I think
you're supposed to because I think the
bags
I don't know that's right don't hesitate
you know I wouldn't yeah he wouldn't
hesitate kill these guys let's see if I
take up a little one I might be fast
enough to catch the big one no I think
this is the bad pass you want it to be
like me shoot I can't tell you you trust
the evil voice do you trust that you
avoid should you trust a kid why would
you want to kill again I are fine killed
the other people the other guy now let's
let the stream decide do we listen to
the evil voice yellow voice or the kid
cuz the kid clearly well you're not
killing him technically he's walking off
the plane the plank to where though by
the way if you guys didn't know we're at
the cement smart home sick then TV but I
need to know Dennis the kid I'm 50/50
okay mystical Misha says evil voice
that's two two two one
welcome back Misha Bailey will maybe
that's three for the evil voice yeah
four for the evil voice the kid might be
a trap shoot the big guy says unanimous
alright I guess that's enough good oh
you only blew off his arm
things play your part oh my gosh they
really want me to go that's good no you
can shoot him again right yeah you know
he's so creepy
you thought you could be me you will
always be just a scared little boy hey
you saw says he died anyways lose
loosely oh oh whoo - whoo oh no oh no
this could be bad news shouldn't have
trusted Chet oh that's because I was
well she is what who I was a moment ago
is no more she was here talking about
acting I can become someone else now we
lost oh we had to have last night let's
get out of here back
oh it's boarded up oh yeah it's fine
oh oh here we go oops or it's a Narnia
all right this is not the sequel I can't
always trust us you're probably right
yeah we're gonna get another key when
there's the cracking gets up all right I
gotta get in that office
oh snap assistant to the general manager
oh man okay my heart all right okay we
got to be good right yeah we're making
progress here
it was all kinds of compare at wonder
that's what he was gonna say hey come to
tickle the handle again come on oh we
running all right that one's bright up
cuz I guess I went oh we have three
options
let me say that now famous last words he
loves gold half a world away okay no
your button doesn't work I said oh it's
slide I think for the film um so we need
some power there's definitely more stuff
to investigate to you yeah
rocket ship oh I'm gonna craft uh I
think you can climb up those stairs now
it's you after oh there's a power down
there hmm
JK Oh another rocket part peace oh nice
okay cool a real puzzle oh you gotta
finish the rocket missing one piece
prepare for liftoff is it in that box up
there it isn't the window
oh yeah or not no I do what you wish
press it again nope can't press it again
oh here we go
let's get inside of it my brother he was
always that okay following in my
instance yeah don't hit anything
silent smiling sadly who asteroids come
in hide on the right can you go down oh
oh okay we're drifting yeah is this
initial BL across town we'd sneak out of
the house he'd look up into the night
sky watching the stars but never really
seen again so I couldn't move it like
left and right so what a face thousand
souls on fire geez his eyes would light
up the stars were already there no no I
knew he had it in him we're here to make
a thousand hearts bleed a thousand heads
turn
but if you beat the game my pretty sure
game decided you never know dreaming
that it would come when we could leave
it all behind I see the Sun back there I
think the journey of the life for the
face oh we blew up a light ball risin he
looks pretty happy so blown up to cool
his boat yes I see had it in him to make
a thousand souls bud make them feel
alive make them live forever a thousand
lives
but nevermind nevermind
I can't stop staring at this guy's face
this five chapters Oh Oh one-eyed
monster take it
we've crashed
now we blew it up the new condition
something behind you
you think we're back on the boat we came
back from space to get back on the boat
you guys what if we're on that okay no
and we're back we were definitely in our
groove you know that looks
another key please yes one Georgy now
yeah we're gonna go the bathroom it's
about time yeah about 45 minutes about
time to go back sure you running around
this place alright we continue on yeah
they've only gotten me once really got
me once real good but that's because it
was already dark we've got these creepy
kids voices and everything you know this
is that pretty interesting way to kick
off the week I know right good scare you
three like right around the corner right
you had to handle some some of this type
of fear before III fear
all right so we are knocking these rooms
down on the bathroom yeah it's time to
go has to be nope what's the voice that
is like I don't want to say Chinese you
bait me
wait this is there's something there to
your left on the ground
Oh what time to make a lemonade that
lemon just like shocked my brain cells
oh yeah you know we don't need that
scary music thanks where's the bathroom
oh here we go
nailed it it's the first one a crime I
turned that water on yeah we gonna flood
this room it's like where's the other
faucets mm-hmm what else is in here
can't get out all right of course check
the toilet maybe know pretty standard
toilet
oh my getting too close to that thing
was gonna be all him oh boy Oh can you
play the puzzle
okay no but I bet you know where we're
gonna go it's just take a right and then
a left and then I left
no he's a big boy write this out okay I
think oh it doesn't let you bring it
with you no that would be nice
let's look at it one more time oh okay
you know what we won't get lost it's
fine
oh no I don't want to do stuff like that
look in keyholes that was an accident
and I wait just kidding you heard okay
all right you turn that fan on Russell
Russell those hands a little bit like
that I don't work
hey hey guys do you like win no it
doesn't sound like it all right of
course see don't be looking in people's
when he shouldn't be but
yeah put something else on yeah I think
so peekaboo the door open I think oh
stop oh look there's a lotta heads
falling they all fall down you're in
another room okay oh there's something
here left there or funny
another door okay scuse me the next
objective alright so it looked like I
hit this and then I ran over and hit
this and then that did something last
time okay
nothing wrong with just raining heads
pretty sad we can't be pretty standard
stuff here no shadow
we're vampires I also realize I have to
stop staring at your screen a little bit
because it's making me a little sick oh
yeah
maybe I have to catch one of these heads
since I'm pretty good logic
oh boy Oh sometimes there's like oh no
it's not like right on top of it
what is this we're playing layers our
fear - it's a psychological thriller
horror oh my goodness
it's like there's only two things in
this room oh wait you're making the vine
go up right when you do that you see how
the vine is so we need to have this
thing below the hands over so I can grab
it
Chadd are we missing anything ain't no I
am missing
what did i do differently last time what
was the plan under the sink I don't
think you can do anything with that
right oh oh oh I see
okay now the heads are you turned it off
hey
pull it I know I'm like those aliens
with my hands into the perfect place
okay maybe we just make it rain a little
bit of heads a slight trickle of heads
aha okay no there we go
good work okay sink try it yeah thank
you
yeah oh I think this is what it's
supposed to look like and then I have to
make it like that I can only assume all
right I'm gonna try to mental you
remember what that looked like well
there's something here there's a bunch
of stuff now there's that there's this
thing now oh that wasn't in there so we
don't need that guy
it wasn't raining him
is it glowing like leaves
okay so we're trying the other process
of elimination we don't get there Eric
is neglecting chat I am NOT I see all of
you
Heiser I'm not intending to it's just
I'm actually so lucky scared that well I
should have paid more attention on what
the thing look like if that's what we're
trying to accomplish here
up music game
[Music]
yeah the crab hand definitely Oh crab
hand where'd that come from
when I turn this thing on the crab hand
comes off but you said it also wasn't
raining heads right great
five Slammy who is that person that told
me to check the sink I need your help
again you might have been some believe
oh you guys
nothing else because the first time I
turn this on and the second I'm going to
turn these off for one off
this is easily the hardest puzzle and
last fear - oh nice look through the
keyhole no see image you'll need to
match this image to turn on the rain use
the taps to make the win press the music
one let's grow the plant now once you've
matched the first image look through the
keyhole on the left this will introduce
the radio in the room the radius which
is the scene from day to night oh it's a
moon I was like that's definitely a crab
hint didn't give me the answer all right
you see it through the keyhole of the
other keyhole no right doesn't let you
the the other side one that one we can't
look through it you know jeez I remember
the Sun for sure I feel like this is it
huh all right that didn't help me so let
me look somewhere else
but I had it read already had to match
what you saw I think so yeah there's
definitely no heads it was definitely a
son
unless it's supposed to be opposite
all right it was daytime this is what we
know it was not raining heads that's
also let me know
I also don't think it was very windy
either I would try to find out for you
mmm-hmm more solutions coming a little
bit
come on
nope
[Music]
and then I went in chat beat this puzzle
that's re job man
I feel like I tried every combination
though I really wish I stared at the
thing more I should have stayed at it
worried because we're clearly missing
something
hey you definitely saw the Sun there was
definitely no moon and then when you and
then you tried it with Oh what's all
that swirling stuff that's the winds
there was no wind right or was there I
remember I don't remember either but
both of these don't work okay how do I
get rid of the hands I don't remember
seeing hands
[Music]
pot and shadows puzzle first part yeah
yeah second part we're cheating you guys
this one second okay you have to turn
you have to turn on the radio you have
to use the right sink
don't touch the left one and then once
you've done both steps interact with the
pot
that was like the opposite oh my god we
did it all right I don't know what the
heck it was opposite I think yeah it was
like instead of a sunny day is a rainy
day
[Music]
cuz if I did that was unintentional but
we know what to do now so yes what did
you miss you missed us having a pro you
can press anyone
I actually know I was using game
pressures guide Chris all Google brought
us to the right place all right all
right I'm out I'm free I guess you just
ran into the screen without even knowing
it
this store is open now so it's all right
now I don't know what you got to do so
here we go yeah I don't know that just
feels right oh this is the maze we gotta
go back to the beginning okay okay okay
okay
so you hung a right so yeah I remember
it wasn't right quick left right I think
it yeah yeah is only way left
are we over complicatedness are we sure
this is the maze this has to be this I I
forget about this way and then LS o x so
dark
that's the way I came what was your
first horror game
I'll answer and then Persia can answer
ah whew that's a tough one
maybe Persia should go first oh there's
the eye ball must have only one eye
dad must only have one eye
[Music]
we're good we're good Oh stay away from
the light
yeah oh now this is the maze well I
don't know where I started and this is
definitely not the way but oh oh say
what does this a spot it's a safe spot
yeah
joke's on you it's time to go here we go
yeah yep crawl space safe in the crawl
space can't laser beam you there okay oh
boy I'm 100% lost okay okay that's a
little nook he got us okay so here I
think I think it's I think you go the
way it has you going and then you just
have to avoid the light I think that's
what it is I don't think it's like a Oh
put you back here that's
you know what it's running that way so
it's selling me I should probably go
that way huh
all right we're chillin till we see the
light can come from either way right
because you got brick watch out
oh no that looks like stone in a circle
there was a nuke therapy dude yep
flights coming okay joke's on him
Oh oh there it is okay I mean some of
its gonna be challanger cuz like you
either have to find a safe spot or
you're just gonna have to like book it I
don't even remember being at this part
but okay last time when I ran I thought
the light was coming from the other
direction but it wasn't I just needed
she decided to eat more and looked at
the walkthrough and that was coming
great well I hope we make it in the next
half an hour I know I feel good about
this puzzle I'll tell you that we'll see
what happens after that crime is Eric's
dad I think he's he could yeah he would
have had to have me really young I'll
say that much yeah there's one right
there so you can chill for a bit it's
definitely gonna come this way we know
that I don't know where the next
crawlspace is though because I didn't
see it
and it's like you know weird like this
like this weird ass tree area okay space
there that's cool I go it muffles the
music's yeah you're like tuning it out
which way is it coming from though okay
that's interesting
you're safe just kidding haha
I think that I think that I think that
is the way though I think that one you
just have to wait longer it probably
makes you think like oh yeah you're safe
I think you're clearly not saying go to
you right yeah it came from the other
side this time so there are some
variants which is cool I guess bad for
us
trying to speedrun it
I wasn't confident oh yeah we gotta wait
again even though it goes green we gotta
wait again until we see it pass us we're
not going anywhere
you got us once you won't get us again
what the hell is this just not I just
want to see it go by one I don't think
it or is it going by the other side why
not that's weird
okay I'm going after this yeah I agree
with that decision okay there it is yeah
yeah you're following it that's good
JK that's a nuke we chillin the
background music is funny item feels
more serious than that but you say so
she got me again person company again I
was like totally good in touches she
jump scared which like made my heart
kind of go Boop alright there's a boat
I'm super laws think you're okay I think
I go back up okay that was a different
animation there yeah we want a good
distance okay I was like oh what did we
call it [ __ ] we made a mess no can't see
you mean but we're runnin
okay there's that's definitely bad a
nice little bench there that's where I
want to sit all right okay she knew
better than she knew better than that
I'm just gonna walk out of here I got
you baited it hasn't done that yet it
didn't do that yes that's the first time
I've seen a path back there elevating I
got you baited all right
screw you flame oh look it's like on a
zigzag way okay okay come back
okay oh it actually comes up over here
oh yeah look at you playing it real
close I like it
oh you're going real safe yeah I get it
this is gonna come back yeah I'm wait
until he comes back around before cuz
this game you know came out the 28th
though he made which would have been
five or so days ago I believe man this
was definitely the maze layup oh we made
it
that was that was we weren't gonna die
from there impossible
okay so did the mother and the brother
die or something
that's what I'm starting to think now
that I saw that this game is dark a
after I know great for streaming right
everyone see everything all right time
to loot some pills no thanks
sounds like a person on problem bro it
is it's over oh geez no mr. Hardy it's
only just beginning
well I'm her back hi I'd like another
key hey we made it the only spirits
isn't a dream no key no key this time
wowzers I don't feel good about that
alright never load screen noticing Oh
normally Wow Oh dead end
oh this is for the next chapter oh you
beat it yeah like all the goods I know
all the goodies next chapters breathe
apparently there's five chapters so
maybe we'll get through a little bit of
this one before we end the stream there
wasn't that much yeah it was pretty tame
like in terms of like compared to the
first two chapters I felt like this one
was more about figuring stuff out
unless about my surviving the monster
that was chasing me the first two acts
alright so I woke up yeah don't forget
y'all we are hanging out at the Xfinity
scene at smart home
chillin streaming hanging out thanks
everyone for tuning in we appreciate it
as okay I can its character yeah clearly
it smells caring yeah I play hangman
okay alright oh look it's the guy I
killed him
where's the other guy they didn't care
about where's this dinner buddy oh man
we're all I'm on drugs
oh no their felt is it filling oh yeah
that's what I was doing before the
stream one two alright so I am I'm
actually about these areas up here I
feel like I'm sure I should be putting
things in here but no all right so let's
go put this new tape in so we can get
ourselves over to act number fo more
creepiness surprised he didn't get
another arm up there it is right on cue
of course I shall be lost shout and then
posture
science
okay you did save a stylist Wow that's
it boom ding that one's creepy at least
the last few it was some like long
elaborate intro I wanted you to feel it
soak it all in
consider it soaked oh man okay alright
we're just right in the thick of it now
oh man we got these big metal doors now
when I was running from the monster I
had to like shut big metal doors so and
there the site that I have to like Oh
get ready I am don't do feel like de
Nimes jeans or he uses shame
that other scary game and everyone in
chat will go here we go
I knew something bad was gonna happen is
a amnesia I think that's like I think
Slenderman or amnesia is when my first
horror games oh yeah that was really uh
one of my first horror games jeez I
don't even know I know that I'm like
notoriously like skittish so I try not
to play as many I played that Silent
Hill demo and that thing that was rated
scary
wait there was nothing here I'd say
first horror games I don't know first
games that got me scared I don't know I
felt like I didn't my parents probably
didn't let me play that maybe horror
games because I was definitely as I have
to get scared of movies and have
nightmares and they're like no one no
more no work for you there was a you
read the note right yes I'm guessing
you're not a child anymore
yeah I'm I'm tall again alright that's
good
Oh course lock me in
I must have missed something in here oh
here we go
that's a lot - but we got more audio
cues so see anything I can interact with
just yet
I read that already
has to be something over here
we're not alright like him into their
locks over here went to this other door
another door some broken glass
silverware Oh what that wasn't there a
second ago was it I don't know uh we
didn't hear an audio cue so something
else could happen
oh the ace up his sleeve that's what I'm
talking about my screen was the last
smaller so he crept away real slow on my
screen again Persia got me again because
the desk move tonight I flinched because
of it so you're not coming through this
way I'll tell you that oh my god okay
let's be open sick all right so let's
look for more panels that look like they
could be doors like this
good man a mic it's not even that scary
right it was just a mannequin but it's
like the way they made him pop out like
he had to get out dude he he had to go
to the bathroom this looks like it could
be a door how did I activate that I
don't know I thought you just like
triggering an audio cue which then
triggered wait so the doors are popping
up randomly is the thing is there
anything over there to the right
Winchell extreme challenge I don't yeah
I don't have ice in my veins and then
both doors were locked right one side
find an empty bag that was from crime so
okay also I'm sorry I'm like trying to
help you but at the same time I'm trying
to like not because I'm like getting a
little motion yeah I can't control where
I'm looking so I'm like looking where
you're looking at I'll try to move less
awkwardly no no you should do what you
need to do I'm just gonna look a check I
can also just look this up to you I like
feeling I should be looking in here
because that's where this door was that
but now I don't know
freaking mannequin man he still has me
on edge yeah apparently there aren't
that many in Chapter four Oh
I guess this isn't even part of the
puzzle second apparently should have
been through this part already is like
Kazan I don't know
Oh see luckily oh snap
okay so I have to walk around a certain
way okay for this to show up okay we
learning where you're learning I would
not have figured that out okay that's
where you got the right behind game I
felt good about that the mind games now
open up after the movie poster I thought
we got the movie poster already yeah we
did
alright we got some nice empty bag
what's with that little stutter yeah I
like zoomed in too I was like what's
going on
oh no magic trick it's all an optical
illusion oh my god okay ease F wah okay
- my name is for you I will you got it
you just stay right there you know we
want anything to worry about oh yeah I
don't like the noises and the mute the
sound effects that's how they get you
that's the whole point my guy's walking
slower and slower
I can't run upstairs oh man it keeps on
going should I go in here thank you
excuse all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay oh we've entered another dimension
gravity oh oh oh what in the world I'm
laying down now on the floor I guess
whoa now this is something that's um
going to this door can you even okay so
this is the ground sorry
no this is so weird
okay okay alright um I'm pretty sure
that is where I should oh this is great
okay you can't walk up that this is wild
and I don't like it so let's go check
out upstairs for a little sounds good
I'm gonna be checking out nothing oh I
can't walk up there is all i yeah oh
gosh yeah if you thought you were
getting motion sickness before well this
I saw I can I stop okay
have you ever have you ever watched The
Hurt Locker the movie okay it that that
movie put me in The Hurt Locker I had to
like walk out of the movie theater
because I couldn't I couldn't handle it
it made me like super sick well you open
the door so that's good no maybe I have
to go back out to where it's normal
leaves and walk through it somewhere
else
was it locked it up or down
that's a good question that thing was
making me dizzy there for a second this
is bored it off oh boy alright we've
just got a shuffle up and deal
real quick I'm like turning my head as
if that's gonna help anything okay do
you see how can I maneuver this so that
I'm
No
there we go ah well like I could get in
here if my character would bow that way
says you can loose items when rotate a
lot what motion sickness is real it's
it's super real for me hikiko I stopped
I can't even help right now because
it'll just make me sick oh there we go
what'd you do I crouched nice this is
bad news these little white lions here
really this is bad news things like this
popped up when the other guy yeah what
he's probably what crown was talking
about
[Music]
okay still good I'm dead oh no are we
though alive
oh no we're a lot
that's our friend remember
I up say oh there we go
we are upside down folks this is cool
lose the character find yourself I think
I chose some points are not to be played
[Music]
crime how much farther are we from what
you want to see because we're running
out of time my dude I'll try my best to
get there quick oh man
Oh yep oh boy run oh oh okay okay oh
that was use you saw falling I guess so
Oh interesting
are we back in reality I suppose so okay
so oh here we go
[Music]
oh this Louis yeah okay I'd like to run
that's a guy crouch he's scared I'm
scared just felt like the right way to
go the rats know what's up they're
afraid to yeah yeah okay we're back in
the area when we started in the
beginning no don't you close on me
there's none Oh warping Oh real oh my
god Petey we're just teleporting Oh
we've gone that way what okay go that
way anyways JK
excuse me I did that backwards he told
us not to do it you guys we did it
anyways so it would happen oh man Oh No
did I die
that means it tell us not to do it like
our screen in the back was is red too
don't do it we had to yeah we had
something we had a choice we realize oh
we're back in the was that the whole
chapter no cuz you never got a real
right and there's a this is a puzzle I
think oh okay there was a puzzle room
with the protector anyways
nice think you wanna kind of wanna try
this I don't know if this is a puzzle I
just know that there was something that
looked like that that was like somewhere
oh yeah sometimes when they do stuff
like this stuff will appear in the
screen but
[Music]
they go ahead and say that's not the
case
[Music]
okay yeah there's the door
we solved it guess we're not stopped
[Music]
me every time oh my God he's gone oh god
oh god okay if we don't run into the
puzzle
you got it I believe you okay
they can't break look at it
sake TV part blew up yeah okay all right
yeah oh my gosh it never ends
well we wanted the puzzle you guys we
did that's messed up okay yeah see my
heart can actually take much more than
this son why am I always the one why
weren't you there why didn't you protect
me
[Music]
oh come on really that was all outside
all right yeah speed running speed
running oh boy I can't run very fast can
never just walk through one door in this
place oh come on that's rude
and there's a guy's face in that thing
whereas it's possible it's silly I think
it's silly I don't think it's happening
unless you really want to see what's in
here but this is the last room Persia I
got to cut it off at this actually you
know what if you guys want to see what
happens
that guy's like in the Box like moving
you see it oh yeah right there but but
this is where we're stopping yeah you
can still zoom in because you can still
see it on the back TV there yeah yeah
and plus you guys came just came out so
we don't want to spoil the whole thing
for you guys I'm personally gonna keep
playing this probably in the office
because I want to know now so but yeah I
enjoyed it I mean like I get scared off
of everything
so horror games you know that's just
kind of how it rolls for me yeah I was
scared because you were scared but
thanks everyone for tuning in again
we're chilling at the Xfinity scene at
smart home in San Francisco and we're
gonna be back for a couple more streams
later in the month after e3 so you see
Persia pricing me at some point maybe a
special guest here and there but yeah
that was layers appear to part of it go
check it out came out was it last week
right yeah that's one yeah but check it
out if you want to but until tomorrow
we're back on gamespot live 11:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time see y'all later
see ya who's home